thank you for joining us I'm John
langler we're going to start here this
afternoon with the holiday travel rush
and the message from Travel Experts if
you can leave today do it the reason
well it's a huge winter storm sweeping
across the country right now about the
same time tomorrow and Friday are going
to be very busy Before Christmas he just
saw some pictures there from the Pacific
North Northwest the storm has already
forced hundreds of flight cancellations
that's Seattle
165 million Americans Coast to Coast are
facing this winter weather head on
we had no idea that our flight was even
going to be delayed or we probably would
have changed our flights but we didn't
know until we were on our way to the
airport oh that's why you got to check
online speaking of which let's check
online here's a look at the departures
and arrivals at Reed international
airport right now so far there have been
131 delays and 17 cancellations today
always be sure don't be like that woman
there check and double check your flight
reservation before you have to go
anywhere anytime soon